For sin shall not have dominion over
you.
For ye are not under the law,
but under grace.
What then?
Shall we sin because we are not under
the law, but under grace? God forbid.
Know ye not that to whom ye yield
yourselves servants to obey, his
servants ye are to whom ye obey?
Romans chapter 6 verses 14 through 16.
Welcome everyone to Q&A with Elder Randy
Skeete. I am your host Danisha Kerchen,
and today we will be discussing law and
grace.
In the realms of Christianity, there are
typically two views, where some say that
because Jesus has died for us, we need
not keep the law because we are under
grace. Whereas others cling to the law
and have a legalistic view of
Christianity. Today, we'll be seeing
what God has to say about law and grace.
But before we go any further, let us
have a word
[clears throat and cough]
prayer.
Dear Lord, we come before you, unworthy
and undone. But we know that in you
there is power, there is strength, there
is wisdom, there is understanding, there
is clarity, dear Lord. And so we're
asking that you would forgive us of our
sins and give us an in-filling of your
Holy Spirit. Especially be with your man
servant Elder Randy Skeete. Put your
words in his mouth. Restore his
strength. Renew his strength, dear Lord.
And I pray that today we will have a
better understanding of the plan of
salvation and be drawn closer to you.
In Jesus's name we pray. Amen. Amen.
Our special guest this afternoon is no
stranger to us, and he has become a part
of the Word Inspired family. He's an
international speaker and is actually
right now in Nubia, where he had a Q&A
right before this one. So we thank God
that he is on fire for the Lord and has
dedicated his life [clears throat]
to God's service. Indeed, he is a nice
man, and he is
intentional about making relationships
with people that will lead them to a
relationship with Jesus Christ. So
please join me in welcoming Elder Randy
Skeete.
Thank you, my dear sister. I'm always
delighted to be with you and those who
are listening, wherever you are.
May the Lord bless you, and may the Lord
through his spirit open all of our eyes
that we may acquire a better, clearer,
deeper view of the concept of law and
grace. As usual, my dear sister Dr.
uh Danisha, I am honored to be with you.
I really am. And wherever I travel, I
run into people who tell me, "Please
tell Dr. Danisha that we watch your
program." And that's the case right here
in Namibia, where I am. There are people
who watch your Q&A. So may the Lord
continue to enable you to pursue this
very, very uh spiritual and blessed
ministry that he has entrusted to you.
Thanks for having me.
Uh Amen. We thank you for your
dedication to the work of the Lord.
Thank you, Elder Skeete. Amen.
also sharing the word of God wherever
you go. And thank you to all of you that
are listening. Elder Skeete let me know
he has some guests with him in Namibia.
So thank you all for joining this Q&A.
So let's begin by defining what is the
law.
In the Bible, the law can refer to the
Ten Commandments,
the ceremonial law,
or the Torah, which is the revealed will
of God
for the Israelites. So one has to
determine uh contextually whether it's
the ceremonial law, the moral law, or
the law as it refers to God's revelation
to his people as to how they should live
their lives. So Torah can Torah can be
specific, or it can be broad.
Indeed, indeed. And I just want to share
this uh this quote here that Ellen G.
White had uh
written.
Uh
Here we go.
Yes.
Uh
Yes. Okay. So Review and Herald, May 6,
1875, paragraph 4. She says, "God's
people, whom he calls his peculiar
treasure, were privileged with a twofold
system of law, the moral and the
ceremonial. Mhm. One pointing back to
creation to keep in remembrance the
living God who made the world, whose
claims are upon all men in every
dispensation, and which will exist
through all time and eternity. Mhm. The
other given because of man's
transgression of the moral law, the
obedience to which consisted in
sacrifices and offerings pointing to the
future redemption. Each is clear and
distinct from the other. So as you
pointed out, Elder Skeete, one uh the
law can even refer specifically to the
Decalogue, the Ten Commandments, or
[clears throat]
the first five books of the Bible, the
Torah. Mhm. So thank you for defining,
Elder Skeete, uh what the law is. Now
we're going to add to that.
What is grace?
The common definition of grace, very
widely accepted, is grace is the
unmerited favor of God. Grace is that
quality of God which allows him to do
for us what we cannot absolutely do for
ourselves. Uh we first encounter grace
in Genesis 6:8. After God describes the
wicked people from verse 1 to 7, he
says, "But Noah found grace in the eyes
of the Lord." So grace is the act of God
on behalf of a helpless person.
An act that God is not obligated to
perform, but he performs it out of the
goodness of his heart. That is grace.
Grace is also power to live a life that
pleases God.
The Bible says, "Grow in grace."
We do that through the study of the word
of God and obedience to that word. We
grow in grace. We grow in that power,
that strength to obey God. But
fundamentally, grace is that divine
quality that allows God to act on our
behalf, even though we do not deserve it
and never will deserve it,
and did not request it.
It is unmerited, unrequested, but
absolutely necessary.
For instance, when Jesus spoke to
Zacchaeus in Luke chapter 19, he told
him in verse 10, "The Son of Man is come
to seek and to save that which was
lost."
Christ coming to seek is an act of
grace. Without that seeking, the saving
could not take place. At every step of
salvation, actually, we see the
expression and the demonstration of
God's grace.
That's powerful, Elder Skeete. And I
really like how you started where grace
is first first mentioned. Mhm. I said,
"Grace is actually an Old Testament
phenomenon." Mhm. Noah was the first one
to experience God's grace. And then when
we saw a lot as well, when the angels
came to take Lot away, Lot said, "You've
been so gracious to me. You showed me
great mercy. Now please let me go to
this little city nearby Sodom." That's
right.
appearing even with Moses.
God revealed himself to Moses as the
merciful God, gracious, long-suffering.
So God's grace is an Old Testament
phenomenon, but God's grace gives us the
power and the ability to grow in him.
And I really love how you said we didn't
ask for it. No.
have to do it for us, Mhm.
granted us grace.
Let me let me add this, uh my good
sister.
We can trace grace all the way to the
Garden of Eden.
Because the Bible says that Adam and Eve
hid themselves from the presence of the
Lord God.
And in verse 9, it says the Lord God
called unto Adam and said unto him,
"Where art thou?" God came looking for
Adam. That was an act of grace. Now the
word grace first appears in Genesis 6:8,
but it was because of grace that God
came looking for Adam and Eve to save
them. The object of grace is the
salvation of the sinner. The object of
grace is the preservation of the sinner.
The object of grace is the admission of
the sinner into the eternal kingdom.
Amen. Amen.
Mhm. I love how you're you're building
the context as to which grace can be
applied, which is
Right. a good segue to our next
question. Mhm. Since we have defined
what the law is, and we've defined what
grace is, what is the relationship
between law and grace?
The law reveals to man his sin, or to
people.
The law identifies and defines sin. The
law is not designed to
save. The law is designed to reveal the
standard God requires. And as I said
earlier, it reveals what is right, what
is wrong, what is sin, what is
righteousness. Grace is that which
enables us to meet the demands of the
law. And the demands of the the demand
of law is simply a sinless living. The
Bible says in Psalm 19:7, "The law of
the Lord is perfect, converting the
soul." If the law is perfect, the only
thing the law accepts is a perfect life.
But we cannot live that life. So grace
also is the fact that Jesus Christ came
to live the life, and if we accept him,
that life of total victory over sin is
credited to us as long as we are in
Jesus Christ. And so the law is a
standard. The law is also, quite
accurately, a lifestyle, but it is only
achievable through the grace of God. So
the law tells me I need grace to meet
its standards. Christ gives me that
grace, and that grace brings me up to
the standard of the law. They cannot be
separated even though they're different.
The law does not give grace,
but grace brings me to the place where
the law acknowledges that my life meets
its very, very high standards. And the
person who makes all of that possible
uh possible is Jesus Christ.
Amen. Amen. And I want to read this
quote here that was uh
that I had put Well, not quote, but
verse that I had put in the notes. Here
in John 1:17, the Bible says, "For the
law was given by Moses, but grace and
truth came by Jesus Christ."
So, not necessarily that the law, the
Ten Commandments, or even the Torah was
Moses' words. It was God's manifestation
of his standard to us. Mhm. Through
Jesus Christ, we have the ability, one,
through the law to recognize our need,
and then two, grace
for that need to be fulfilled, to
salvation through Jesus Christ. Well,
the fact that the law was given by
Moses, but grace and truth came through
Jesus, but whatever came through Jesus
operated in the days of Adam and Eve. We
must remember that. Because all people
are saved the same way in all ages and
dispensations. The Apostle Paul, or
Silas, or Barnabas, they were saved the
same way Abraham was saved, or Adam, or
Seth, or Enoch, any of those mighty
patriarchs.
Now, Moses
was the servant God used to present the
law to Israel.
The law did not originate with Moses. In
the person of Christ, who is also an
agent of the Father, but who is also
God, so Christ himself is both the
source of the law, the source of truth,
and the source of grace. Moses is
exclusively the agent God used, not the
source of grace or the source of truth.
Also, with respect to the first part of
that that verse, the law was given by
Moses,
the law, the Ten Commandments were given
directly to the Israelites. God spoke
them directly to all 2 million
Israelites at the same time. The
ceremonial law was given directly to
Moses. Moses wrote them in a book, and
then declared them to the Israelites.
But Moses did not have to declare the
Ten Commandments to the Israelites. They
heard God speak them himself. And so,
with respect to the law coming through
Moses, it may be safer to to conclude it
is more to ceremonial law than the moral
law. Even though Moses came off the
mountain with the two tables of stone in
his hand, but the Israelites heard what
God had spoken, which was written on the
tables, but they heard nothing about the
ceremonial law. And so, in a more direct
sense, Moses is connected to the
ceremonial law because he had to speak
it to the Israelites, but God spoke the
moral law directly to all 2 million
Israelites at the same time. So, yes,
the law came through Moses, but in a
more intense way,
ceremonial law because the Israelites
did not hear the ceremonial law at all.
So, Moses had a direct responsibility to
declare that law to the Israelites.
Amen. Amen. And I just want to put a
nail in a short place. Elder Skelton,
read two verses here from the the book
of Deuteronomy chapter 4 verses 12 and
13.
This is Moses talking. He says, "And the
Lord spake unto you out of the midst of
the fire. Mhm. Ye heard the voice of the
words, but saw no similitude. Only ye
heard a voice and You heard a voice.
That's right. Yes. And what did he
declare? And he declared unto you his
covenant, That's right. which he
commanded you to perform, even the Ten
Commandments. commandments. That's
right. And he wrote them upon two tables
of stone. Mhm. Amen. Amen. So, I'm now
going to turn it over, Elder Skelton, to
Brother Kevin Gomez to ask the next two
questions. Okay.
Thank you.
I was muted. Happy Sabbath, Brother
Skelton. It's always a pleasure
you? I'm doing great. Um Good.
It's always a pleasure to hear the word
of God coming from you because it it
comes clear.
Praise God. Mhm. Um the next question
is based on Romans 6:14. What does
living under grace mean?
Living under grace, well, let's not
separate it from under the law. Living
under grace is living within the the
power and the life of Jesus Christ.
Having the life of Jesus Christ lived in
you. Now, Paul in Romans of Romans
Galatians 2:20 said, "I am crucified
with Christ. Nevertheless, I live, yet
not I, but Christ liveth in me." Christ
Paul lived under grace because grace is
what makes it possible for us to obey
God's law because God writes the law on
the heart of a person. That is a
tremendous act of grace because he does
not If he does not
write it, no one can keep that law. Uh
Galatians Galatians 5:18 says, "If you
let of the Spirit, you're not under the
law." And so, led by the Spirit and
living under grace are the same thing.
He or she who lives under grace is being
led by the Spirit of God. Now, let's go
to under the law means to live under the
condemnation of the law. In other words,
the person is living in violation of
God's law and consequently faces that
condemnation, which is death. But the
child of God upon whose heart the law is
written, that person lives in harmony
with the law. That is possible through
the grace of God in writing that law
internally and having the life of Christ
within that person. In a very real
sense, the law of God is the life of
Christ.
Amen. Because the law is righteousness,
and the Bible says Christ is made unto
us wisdom and righteousness and
sanctification and redemption. Christ,
our righteousness. The law is
righteousness. He or she who has the law
written on their heart has Jesus Christ
in the heart.
Amen. I I like that part, the last part
you mentioned that those who has the law
of God those who live under grace are
living and being guided by the Spirit.
They're living in under the the guidance
of Jesus, having Jesus in their hearts.
That is living under grace. Amen.
Amen.
And the next question
um goes like this. What is the new
covenant?
The new covenant is really the old
covenant. Let me explain that quickly
before someone gets a headache from some
any confusion.
When Christ died, his death ratified the
covenant, which we now call the new
covenant.
Prior to his death, it was called the
old covenant, but the contents are the
same, salvation through faith in Christ.
That's how Abraham was saved. That's how
the Old Testament patriarchs were saved,
but Christ had not yet died, so that
covenant was not ratified because Christ
could have changed his mind and gone
back to heaven.
So, it was provisionally the covenant.
When he died, he ratified it with his
blood because for a covenant to be in
force, it requires the death of the
testator. And so, with the death of
Christ, the covenant under which Abraham
was saved became known as the new
covenant. But it is the same covenant,
as I said, that saves Paul and that
saves Abraham because God only has one
method of salvation, not two. And that
method is the new covenant, whether it's
ratified in the new, or before it was
ratified in the old, it was called the
old covenant. Now, there is a covenant
which is based on the works of humanity.
That is the one that leads to bondage.
When Moses told the Israelites what God
said, they replied, "All that the Lord
has spoken, we will do." They pledged to
obey God in their own power. God
accepted that because they made the
arrangement, but they soon discovered
they couldn't do it. I mean, they were
washing they were worshipping the golden
calf very shortly thereafter. That old
covenant is a covenant of works by human
power, which does not yield one
microscopic element of grace in God's
sight or salvation. But the covenant
that saves is the one Abraham was saved
by, Paul was saved by. In Paul day
Paul's day is called the new covenant
because it was ratified. And that
covenant is what Jesus Christ does for
us. But the condition of that
is the Decalogue, the Ten Commandments.
That's why in Exodus 34:28, the
commandments are called the covenant,
but they're actually the foundation of
the covenant because the covenant itself
is different from the Ten Commandments.
But the Ten Commandments are the
condition upon which a person is saved.
To narrow it down to one word, obedience
is a condition of salvation, and the the
Ten Commandments are the expression of
that obedience. So, the the old covenant
was the covenant that saves before
Christ died. When he died, he made it
official and irreversible.
And it was called the new covenant.
A very good reference is Patriarchs and
Prophets page 370 to 373, where Ellen
White speaks very clearly about this new
covenant and the old covenant.
Patriarchs and Prophets 370 to 373.
But all people are saved under the same
covenant. All.
Amen. Minister Jesus Christ is through
faith in him that we can be saved.
That's right. I was um
remembering something that um Jesus told
us a new commandment, but it was just um
as you mentioned, he was bringing to
memory again, rectifying
um the commandment. He says in John
13:34, "A new commandment I give you,
love one another."
And that has been repeated on the Old
Testament so many times, but sometimes
we need to remember.
It needs to be repeated to us. It needs
to be ratified to us. Thank you, Elder
Skeete.
Well, let me also say this, my good
brother. Sin is violation of the law.
When a man is saved, or woman, that
person is saved, and that person is
enabled to live in harmony with the law.
So, the law can never be removed from
the plan of salvation. The law cannot be
separated absolutely from grace. Let me
say it again. Sin is the violation of
the law.
Righteousness, a righteous life, is a
life in harmony with God's law. When
someone is converted, that person is
brought into harmony with the law of
God, which means he's brought into
harmony with God's great standard, with
God himself.
Amen. Let's consecrate ourselves to be
in harmony with Jesus, and the Bible
says that we can do nothing without him,
but we can do all things through Christ.
That's right. That's right. Thank you,
Elder.
I'll give it back to Denisha.
All right. Amen. Amen. Thank you so
much, Brother Gomez, for asking those
questions, and Elder Skeete for
responding with the word of the Lord.
One of the points I appreciate is that
you emphasize that this is not a new
covenant per se. It's
God has one method of salvation. There
is
one name given under heaven whereby we
must be saved.
Whereby we must be saved. That's right.
is the voice, the name of Jesus Christ.
Christ. And I I just want to share this
text, Hebrews chapter 8, verse 10.
It says, "For this is the covenant that
I will make with the house of Israel
after those days, saith the Lord. I will
put my laws into their mind and write
them in their hearts. I will be to them
a God, and I will be to them a God, and
they shall be to me a people." So, this
is an even more intimate relationship
that God is calling for with his people.
He wants us to have his law, his word,
hidden in our hearts.
All right. And of course, from what you
just said,
we see the law right in the middle of
the new covenant. You know, some people
say, "I'm a new covenant Christian. I
don't have to keep the law."
And they don't realize under the new
covenant, God writes the law right in
the heart of a person. You read it in
Hebrews 8:10. It's also found in Hebrews
10:16, Jeremiah 31:31 to 33. The new
covenant places the law not on tables of
stone, but in fleshy tables of the
heart. Second Corinthians 3:13. So,
those who say, "I'm a New Testament
Christian. I don't need the law." They
do not understand what they're talking
about.
And what was so interesting, even as I
was studying these couple of weeks, you
know, on the topic of law and grace,
when we look at the ark of the covenant
in the most holy place,
the 10 Commandments are given
under the mercy seat. Right.
like they have to go together. The two
are intertwined. God will not give us a
law outside of the context of mercy or
grace, because he knows that in and of
ourselves, in this human frame, we
cannot keep his law. But through the
grace that comes through Jesus Christ,
through the power of his quickening
spirit, we are enabled to become like
him.
Yeah.
Yeah, in fact, there was a verse that
struck me as I was studying. It was
Second Corinthians chapter 3, verse 3.
Let me see if I can flip here quickly.
Here, Paul says, "For as much ye are
manifestly declared to be the epistle of
Christ, ministered by us, not written
with ink, but with the spirit of the
living God, not in tables of stone, but
in fleshly fleshly tables of the heart
of the heart." And I was like, "Lord, I
know there's a lot of significance here
in this verse, but I'm not quite
understanding." For what God revealed to
me is that
Paul said that these people became the
epistle or the letter of Christ. Mhm.
But Jesus is the word of God. But
by the ministration or the work of the
Holy Spirit through these apostles, they
were becoming like Jesus. So, as they
were beholding Christ and listening to
his word and applying their word through
the Holy Spirit, they were changed,
which is probably why the chapter ends
in verse 18 saying, "But we all with
open face beholding as in a glass
the glory of the Lord are changed into
the same image from glory to glory, even
as by the spirit of the Lord."
This is what the new covenant is about,
becoming like Jesus, becoming like God,
who is holy, whose standard is the word
of God, the 10 Commandments.
And the power for that is the life of
Christ
in us.
Amen. All right. So, I went off on a
little tangent there, but
okay. [laughter] That's all right.
That's okay.
[gasps]
So, we have actually completed our core
questions, Elder Skeete, but we have a
long document, 28 pages of open form
questions.
Connected to the law and grace?
Well, not all of them are connected to
the law and grace. Would you like me to
select them to be only connected to the
we we we spend time on one particular
subject. That's true. That's true.
that would be more profitable
than going off in several directions.
That is true. That is true.
Well, let me see.
There's one here that's on testing the
spirits, but mhm, it's not really too
much related.
Well, let me hear that one.
Okay. So, let's scroll back up. Okay.
So, this is from Shenaelea.
She mentioned that she was hearing you
speak on a sermon on testing the
spirits, and I think she just wants you
to break it down. What does it really
mean to test the spirits? This is from
First John 4:1-3.
Mhm.
We see it. Love it. Believe not every
spirit, but try the spirits whether they
are of God, for many false prophets are
gone out into the world. Now, he tells
us how do we know a true spirit? And a
true spirit may simply mean someone
who's preaching, or someone who's
written, someone declaring Bible truth.
If that person believes and declares
that Jesus Christ is come in the flesh,
that person is reliable. If that person
denies that Christ is come in the flesh,
that person is not a true spirit. And
so, the test there is that Christ
actually came in the flesh. You see, in
the days of John, there was something
called Docetism. Docetism taught,
very falsely, of course, that Christ did
not really come. He only appeared to
have come. It looks like he came, but he
did not actually come. And John is
really fighting that teaching in his
epistles. And he's saying, "Listen, a
true preacher you can trust that is one
who comes right out and says Christ
actually, literally, physically,
three-dimensionally came into this
world." And so, that is what we're
talking about when we say try the
spirits whether they are of God. We do
have to keep in mind the context within
which John was writing. He was in a time
when this false doctrine, Docetism, was
very popular, that Christ did not really
come. He did not really die. It just
appeared that way, but it was not a
reality. And John is trying to prove,
"No, it was a reality." And so, he's
saying, "Anyone, any preacher, any
spirit, who tells you he did not
actually come in the flesh, that's a
false spirit. That's the spirit of the
Antichrist."
So, we test the spirits by the word of
God, and the word of God tells us that
Christ, "For as much then as the
children are partakers of flesh and
blood, he also himself likewise took
part of the same." He took part of flesh
and blood. He was physical. He was a
human being. When he rose from the grave
in Luke 24, he said, when he appeared to
the disciples after his resurrection, he
said, "Handle me and see, for a spirit
hath not flesh and bones as you see me
have." You may apply Docetism to spirit,
because you cannot see a spirit. A
spirit may appear to be possibly there
or not there. But Christ says, "No, no,
no. I'm flesh and blood." He says, "Grab
my hand. Handle me." And so, John is
fighting Docetism. And so, he says,
"Anyone who tells you Christ did not
come in the flesh, that is a false
spirit."
And by spirit, anyone preaching.
Amen. Amen. So, Sister Lea, I hope that
you were able to get clarity on that.
And Elder Skeete, I like how you framed
it in the context of what John was
addressing. I remember one time in a one
question and answer segment, you said
that the Bible is a historical book.
Yes.
it's important also to examine or study,
"What was the history? You know, what
was taking on in this setting? What was
John,
[clears throat]
or whatever writer, trying to speak to
or address?" So, thank you for making
that [clears throat] point, Elder
Skeete. Well, let me say quickly, when
we say the Bible is a historical book,
it doesn't mean the Bible only teaches
history. When the Bible deals with
history, it is accurate. In that sense,
it's historical, historically accurate,
but not exclusively
focused on history, but historically
accurate when it deals with history,
scientifically accurate when it deals
with science, psychologically accurate
when it deals with psychology,
sociologically accurate when it deals
with sociology, but not exclusively any
one of those.
Amen. Amen.
All right, Elder Skeete, we have a
question here from Sovereign Hero, and
this one is aligned with the law of God.
Okay.
He says, "In Denisha's last read with
me, she mentions that one must keep the
law of God to eat of the tree of life."
And let me jump out of this quotation.
That's Revelation 22:14.
That's right. He then goes on to say,
"Our father Enoch earned this right and
has been translated in heaven for 5,000
plus years, but But was almost 700 years
after his ascension before the tree of
life was removed from the earth.
Mhm. Did he come down every month?
[laughter]
Okay, go ahead.
Did angels bring the fruit to him? I can
make inferences, but how was he
sustained? But I think this is this last
one. Also, was Lucifer the covering
cherub that covered the law of God or
did Gabriel share in that duty from the
beginning? So, they're actually
Okay, let's deal with the Lucifer one
first and then we get to Enoch coming
down every month.
Yeah. The Bible says in Ezekiel 28:14,
"Thou what? The anointed cherub that
covereth and I have set thee so." Now,
it gives the the the impression that
Lucifer was the anointed the covering
and no one else was. Now, when God gave
Moses instructions for the construction
of the ark and all its furnishings, uh
the tabernacle, there were two cherubim,
one on either side. Exodus 25:19 through
17 through 20.
But Ezekiel tells us before sin, "Thou
what? The
anointed cherub that covereth and I have
set thee so have set you as a covering
and anointing an anointed cherub, a
covering cherub at the I handpicked you
for that." So, there's an intimation
that Lucifer might have been the only
covering one, but I am not speaking with
absolute certainty on that.
Gabriel, we don't know what he was doing
back then.
With regard to Enoch coming down all the
time,
there's no need for Enoch to come down
because the tree of life is in heaven.
God God took it up in the garden. Of
course, it was on the earth quite a
while before he did. God surely has some
way to sustain the people in heaven who
are human like Enoch and Moses and
Elijah and of course those who went up
with Christ. So, there's no information
that Enoch came down
every so often to eat something that's
on the earth. You're in heaven, you're
sustained by whatever you need that's in
heaven. That's what sustains you.
There's no need for someone to come down
to sinful earth to find the nourishment
he or she needs to be sustained. God has
taken you to heaven. He's fitted you for
heaven and whatever nourishment and
sustenance you need surely is provided
in heaven. We read in Psalm 78, I
believe it is, verse 25, "Man did eat
angels' food."
So, there's something called angels'
food. Whether this angels' food because
it was brought by angels or angels
actually consume it, I'm not sure. But
the text says man did eat angels' food.
So, whatever Enoch needs to be sustained
is provided in heaven.
No need to come to the earth all the
time. That would suggest there's an
inadequacy in heaven.
Amen. Amen. Amen.
Thank you, Elder Skeete, for clarifying
that. Thank you for clarifying that.
Now, Elder Skeete, I have a question.
Yes.
In uh
Mark chapter 2:27
and 28, Jesus says
the Sabbath was made for man and not man
for the Sabbath. Therefore, the son of
man is Lord also of the Sabbath. Mhm. We
know that God's 10 Commandments have
always existed. Right. But God created
the Sabbath on the seventh day.
Mhm. Was the Sabbath
around before the earth was created?
Of course. Now,
the Bible evidence is
the first day is Genesis 1:5, evening
and morning were the first day.
We have no other information about days
existing prior to the first week of
creation.
The Sabbath day was introduced
at creation.
The Sabbath principle always existed.
Let me say that again. The Sabbath day
is one day a week. The Sabbath principle
is how we should live every day. The
Sabbath principle simply acknowledges
God as the source of life, the source of
sustenance, the power that sustains and
keeps.
The Sabbath principle lets us know God
deserves our worship. He deserves
everything because he's creator. That
principle functions every day of our
lives. There's no break, no release from
observing the Sabbath principle, which
is the creature depends on the creator.
The creature worship the creator, not
the other way around. The Sabbath day,
which was instituted to specially
highlight that, began, according to
Bible information, at the creation week.
But we have no evidence that days
existed prior to Genesis chapter 1.
Amen. Amen. Thank you, Elder Skeete, for
clarifying that.
I'm now going to allow
let me let me go a little further. The
law is split into love for God, love for
your fellow man. Those are two
principles. You understand? They are
principles.
Let me give an example. Safety is a
principle. 55 mph is a law.
Are you with me?
When the principle of safety operates,
there's in the in the person's heart,
there's no need for a law defining how
fast you should drive. For instance, if
I care about people's safety and I'm
driving to a parking lot, I will slow
down to a crawl because the principle of
safety will lead me to slow down. If I'm
on the highway, I go a little quicker.
When I'm on the plane, I'm so glad it's
traveling 500 mph and not 25. Safety
requires a plane to travel at a high
rate of speed. Safety requires a car to
travel at a lower rate of speed. The
principle of safety remains unchanged,
but the individual laws that express
that safety may change and vary. And so,
principle does not change. The principle
of the 10 Commandments, the principles
are love for God, love for your fellow
man. The individual commandments are,
here is what that means. Here is how you
apply that principle. Don't kill. Don't
steal. Don't lie. Don't be false
witness. Here is how you apply that
principle. Here is how you live the
principle of love.
So, the law, "Thou shalt not," enables
us to express an eternal principle that
has always operated. And so, the
principle of the Sabbath, which is the
principle of dependence,
God is creator. I worship him because
he's creator.
I obey him because he's creator. Long
before there was sin, there was no need
for savior, but there was always
worship. The angels worship God because
he was the creator. In the world, we we
won't have need for savior, but we will
still worship God. Why? There will
always be a creator. So, the Sabbath
principle tells me, "Acknowledge God in
all that I do. In all thy ways,
acknowledge him." Why? Because he is the
creator. And that principle of
dependence always functions seven days a
week. But at creation, God assigned a
specific day for specially
uh emphasizing that principle without
the interference of secular activities
like working and playing and anything
else.
Amen. Amen. Amen. Thank you, Elder
Skeete.
Uh now, Brother Kelly Edwards has a
question that he would like to ask.
So, I'll give him the opportunity to
unmute. And that goes for all of you
participants. If you have a question, uh
specifically pertaining to law and grace
that you would like to pose to Elder
Skeete, feel free to use your the raise
your hand feature so that I can unmute
you and you can pose your question.
All right, Brother Edwards.
Afternoon, sir. Randy Skeete. Good
afternoon. How are you? Uh I'm great,
sir.
Good. Good.
My question to you is,
uh when one is baptized and come to know
the truth and to know the laws of God,
would that person still struggle with
sin or would fall? And if they do,
would they still be grace for them that
was available before they got baptized?
Grace has to be available 24 hours a
day, 60 seconds a minute. You cannot
have a pause in grace. No. A person who
comes to Christ, genuinely comes to
Christ, will fall, yes. The Bible says,
"If any man sin, we have an advocate
with the Father."
An occasional fall does not make you any
less a child of God.
The spirit of God will tell you, "You
fell, get up. Let's move again." The
child of God will fall, but reacts
differently. The one who is not a child
of God couldn't care less whether he or
she falls or not because the the desire
to repent is not there. The person does
not feel that obligation to God. But the
child of God, his or her first
motivation is to please God. When that
person sins, the person is sorry and the
person repents. The person is still
still a child of God. Grace is always
available for the child of God in this
dispensation. Always available.
You cannot have a pause in grace any
more than you can have a pause in God
sustaining the universe.
You don't cease to be a child of God
because you make a mistake.
It is not a jump in the in in the in in
the river on the bank, in the river on
the bank. That's not the way it
functions. You're in the river with
Christ or you're on the bank with
Christ. If you slip, you're still a
child of God. You're just a child of God
who slipped. And the spirit of God will
convict you of your error and out of
love for God, you repent. And you'll be
sorry that you hurt God, but you're
still God's child. Now, if your slips
become a lifestyle, then we have a
problem. So, Paul says sin no longer has
dominion over you. The reign of sin, the
rule of sin is broken in the life of the
person who comes to Christ. The reign of
sin, but the occasional slip will occur
because the Bible says the flesh lusteth
against the spirit and the spirit
against the flesh and these are contrary
one to the other.
Romans uh Galatians 5:17. So, yes, the
possibility of slipping always occurs.
It's always present. But it does not
mean you're not a child of God because
you slipped.
But a slip is not the same thing of as a
lifestyle of sin. A lifestyle of sin
places a person outside the possibility
of being saved.
Not by God's fault, by the person's
fault. The person chooses not to be,
chooses to live outside of the love and
the salvation of God.
But when he or she comes to Christ,
that's Christ's child, the Father's
child. An occasional fall, still the
child of God. But a person must repent.
And a genuinely lover of God will
repent.
Thank you.
Mhm. God bless you.
Amen. Thank you for that question, uh
brother Kelly, and for that answer,
Elder Skeete. God's grace is available
at every moment. That's right. Praise
God for that.
All right. So, I'm going to take a
question now from YouTube.
[clears throat]
Uh this question comes from Jerry.
The question is, what what's the
difference between grace and blessings?
Are God's blessings reserved for the
believer only, those that have an
abiding relationship with him, and not
the unbeliever?
The Bible says in Matthew 5:45, that you
may be the children of your father which
is in heaven. For he maketh the sun to
rise on the evil and on the good, and
sendeth rain on the just and on the
unjust. There are blessings that fall
even on the unbeliever because God still
preserve the whole world. And the
unbeliever, for whom there's still
probationary time, is to some degree
under the blessings of God because
probation is itself a blessing.
Because without probation, there's
destruction. Probation is itself a
blessing. And that blessing operates to
preserve the person that the person may
soon come to acknowledge sin and accept
Jesus Christ. And so, he maketh his sun
to rise on the evil and on the good, and
sendeth rain on the just and on the
unjust. So, God in his mercy does not
turn his back completely on someone who
does not come to him. God wants to save
that person. And so, yes, God's
blessings operate, but not at the
torrential level that they operate for
someone who is a child of God.
God's choicest blessings are reserved
for his obedient children.
But God has preservative blessings that
keep the sinner alive so that he or she
may have a chance to come to Christ.
Amen. Amen. And so, Elder Skeete, what
would you say is the difference or
relationship between grace and
blessings?
A blessing can be seen as an individual
act.
The
uh the person prays to the person prays
to God and says, "Father, I want this or
that." God grants it. That is a
blessing.
Uh there's a blessing health is a
blessing from God. Uh mental clarity is
a blessing from God. Uh your children
walking with God, that's a blessing from
God. So, grace is not an individual
thing. Grace is a pervasive expression
of God's goodness, but blessings can be
individualized.
Amen. Amen.
following me? Blessings can be
individualized.
Grace is an all perva- pervasive
expression of the goodness of God, an
expression of his restless desire to
save people and to preserve those who
need to save. But blessings can be
individualized. I receive this blessing
or that blessing. And then we use the
word blessing very loosely. Someone
gives you $5 on the street, God gave me
a blessing, whether we can define it
that way or not. So, blessings are
individual, they can be. And of course,
the word is loosely used, but grace is
not an individual act. Grace is an
expression of the goodness of God.
Amen. Amen. And may I add, Elder Skeete,
grace is often given in the context to
one that doesn't deserve it.
Well,
grace must include an undeserving
object. Yes. The moment you deserve it,
then that's not grace. Angels in heaven
who've never sinned do not understand
grace
because they never needed grace.
Only a sinner can appreciate grace.
Because without that, that sinner has no
hope.
But the sinless angels don't need grace.
They don't understand grace.
Wow. Wow. Praise God. Mhm.
So, I'm now going to allow brother
Ronmel Horn to unmute to ask his
question. That name sounds familiar.
Yes, he's been on the live before, and
he uploads the videos.
[laughter]
Yeah. Yeah. Yes. Yes.
Um
Yeah. Um so, good good evening, uh
pastor.
Good evening, doctor. How are you? I'm
okay. I'm good.
All right. So, um I'm I'm thinking about
um
Sunday churches, right? Um and the
Sunday Sunday fellowship is um
quite common, and they are big on
praising God and praying and stuff like
that.
And there's a text in the Bible that
says, "Okay,
if you come to God and
you know what is against his law, then
even our prayers become an abomination."
Yes. So,
who are these people?
Uh
well, who who who is answering these
prayers because
I mean, they they they preach a lot,
they sing a lot, but if you're talking
about God saying it requires us to keep
his law,
and um there's a breach in there
it with with them in that they disregard
the Sabbath commandment.
Um
who who who is really answering their
prayers? You know, because these people
You know, these people, you know,
they they they are
very ambitious. Um they they
Okay.
they usually promote, you know, God and
tell people, you know, you know, just
have faith, and they they big on Okay. I
I think I get your point. I think I get
your point, my good brother.
The law can be disobeyed ignorantly or
deliberately. There are some people who
are not yet convicted to serve the day,
the Sabbath. They truly love God.
They've not yet been convicted.
Conviction comes at different time. You
cannot set a time for conviction. Here's
a Bible study, now I require you to be
convicted. It is only the spirit who can
convict, and the spirit knows when to
carry out that act of conviction. So,
there are people who jump and shout and
presumably praise God, but they may be
doing it very sincerely based on the
fund of knowledge they have. Now, if
that person is sincere, when the truth
comes, the person will accept it.
There's another group that simply
believes that going to church is making
some noise, jumping, and then that
praise that pleases God. But the Bible
says, "Herein is my Father glorified,
that you bear much fruit." What is that
fruit? The fruit of the spirit, which is
only possible when Christ lives his life
in you and his law is written on your
heart. So, yes, there are people who
make a lot of noise and pretend to
worship God. Some do it knowing that the
the Sunday is not the Sabbath. Some do
it knowing that whatever they're doing
is wrong, the way they're speaking
tongues is wrong. It is not biblical,
but they're driven by habit and
tradition and popular movements around
them, and they do it. So, they Not all
people who uh violate the Sabbath law is
violating the Sabbath commandment
deliberately. Some simply do not know.
Some have not yet been convicted, and
conviction is the work of God, not the
work of a preacher or Bible worker. And
so, we we have to be very careful how we
pass judgment on because we really don't
know. But true worship to God is based
on obedience.
And in that sense, you're very right.
The foundation of worship is obedience.
That's why God says, "I prefer obedience
over sacrifice." Obedience is the
cornerstone of worship to God.
But there's some people who are doing
whatever they're doing, all they need is
the light of truth, and something will
grip their hearts and their consciences,
and they will change.
So, God in his mercy also intervenes on
behalf of those who out of ignorance are
violating his law.
His intervention does not promote
violation. His intervention promotes the
possibility that that person will change
and come to the light of truth.
Okay. Thank you.
You're very welcome.
Amen. Amen. Amen. Now, Elder Skeete, we
have
uh two questions, well, in fact, three
if I count uh
YouTube,
uh but these are not pertaining to law
and grace.
Um would you like to take the question,
or should we defer for,
you know, another question based on our
topic? Yes, let's do that.
If you have another law and grace
question.
Uh I don't think we do.
[laughter]
I don't think we do, but does anyone
here on the live have a question on law
and grace, something that we spoke about
uh that you would like more clarity on
or more information on when it comes to
the law and to grace?
Well, let's try one of those two
questions you mentioned.
Let's try the first one.
All right. So, the the first one says,
and I
"Should we pay tithe from gross or net?"
Let me ask that person.
If God said If God provided salvation
based on the net, and I told that to my
church earlier today, he would not have
sent Jesus.
The coming of Christ shows us that God
gave from gross. He gave all that he
had. God is a gross giver. We as a
return tithe on the gross, not the net.
You don't return tithe after the
government have snatched or extorted
theirs. We give tithe based on what is
our salary, our increase.
God first, then all other agencies can
follow. Tithe is based on the gross.
God gave Christ from the gross,
not from the net, from the gross.
Salvation expresses the gross nature of
the love of God. We must reciprocate by
giving ourselves, giving what we have to
give from the gross. By the way, when we
surrender to Christ, it must be from the
gross. All that we have we give to
Christ.
You pay a tithe or return a tithe you
don't pay from the gross. You cannot
give God too much. Never be stingy with
God because what you have belongs to
his. He can take all of it and still be
righteous. Give God from the gross. Let
God
do beyond your expectation.
Next question.
Amen. Amen. Thank you, Elder Skeet. And
I just want to acknowledge Sister Stacy
and thank you for joining and helping to
moderate the chat.
Uh she sent me a question here from
Sovereign Hero. He says, "When Adam and
Eve disobeyed the law of God, they were
aware of grace and that Jesus would
come, just as Abraham and David
understood this.
How then did they think Cain was the
deliverer? Were they hopeful, blind? Was
this a
mo
I guess this means Mosaic role in their
minds. Did they, through their disregard
for the law, forever ruin the
Okay, I'm not going to go into that
latter part of the question.
Okay.
But I would
think she got the deliverer when Cain
was born? Sin affected the minds of Adam
and Eve. Sin interferes with the proper
perceptions of God's grace and God's
goodness. So, when Eve, God had promised
them a deliverer.
We don't know all the details God gave
them. God never gives all details. He
gives enough for us to proceed by faith
on his information. Eve being a mother,
and all every Jewish mother hopes that
the
the the redeemer comes through her
because the Jewish nation is still
waiting for the savior to come. So,
every Jewish mother would love to be the
one through whom the Messiah come, the
one who came 2,000 years ago. Eve
thought that Cain was that deliverer.
That's what her thinking as a mother.
I've got the man to the Lord. Sin
affects the capacity to think.
That's why we need the spirit to help
undo that damage.
So, Eve thought Cain was Can you imagine
Cain was Christ?
She thought the first murderer to be was
the savior.
But of course she was wrong. But you
can't blame a mother for hoping that her
son would be the savior of the world.
The moment they sinned, something
happened to their capacity to
comprehend.
Because when they heard Christ, they
ran.
The thinking what They ran and hid.
The mind had been corrupted by sin.
Mhm.
But Cain was anything but the deliverer
to come.
Very true.
We have a question, Elder Skeet, uh from
Camptown Alert. The question is, is is
there grace for a home where one side
seeks to keep the Sabbath while the
other side, who's not converted, does
not keep it?
Are we talking about husband and wife?
I haven't heard that in the question.
to be. It has to be. I would assume it's
one spouse is a Sabbath keeper, the
other isn't.
[clears throat]
God's grace is never fully withdrawn
because even for the one who doesn't
keep the Sabbath, God's grace still
functions to draw that person to the
point of obedience. Now, God's grace is
more fully poured out on those who obey
him, but he does not cut off grace from
the person who doesn't because God wants
to save that person. So, the grace of
God is expressed toward the unbeliever
in ways that will possibly draw that
person to Christ. So, yes, in a divided
home where one obeys, one doesn't obey,
the grace of God can still function.
Now, where there's division, of course
there will be problems. Now, you take a
home where both are united in obedience
from the heart, then all of the
blessings of God are more more they're
greater because both are on the same
page. But in a home where one goes left
or one goes right, the grace of God is
not cut off from the one who doesn't
obey. It still functions to draw that
person. And that grace may function
through the faithfulness of the one who
obeys.
As that person stays faithful, that may
win the unbelieving person. And that is
essentially what Peter tells women in 1
Peter 3:1-3, how to deal with an
unbelieving spouse. Your faithfulness
and respect for the person as your
husband may draw that person without any
nagging or trying to force the person to
come to church. Grace always functions.
Now, if probation closes, then that's no
longer the case.
But as long as there's probationary
period, the grace of God functions to
save that person, however rebellious
that person may be. Nebuchadnezzar was
very rebellious. He was murderous. He
was brutal. He was a tyrant. He was
homicidal. But the Lord saved him
because grace worked and worked and
worked.
Amen. Amen. And the Holy Spirit indeed
is working. Elder Skeet, Camptown
uh uh
affirmed that yes, it's between husband
and wife.
Okay. All right.
Okay. Okay.
Well, it's a
It's about 9:00 where I am.
And I usually go over, but tonight I
have to uh
stick to the 1-hour limit. I hope you
don't mind. Oh, not at all. Not at all.
In fact, we thank you for Okay.
bleeding over to this next Q&A and we
are grateful for your presence. We are
grateful for your presence and your
dedication.
My privilege, my honor, my pleasure,
really.
Thank you. Thank you.
bless all your listeners wherever they
are. And let me tell you again, they
watch you all over the world.
When I say they watch you, I I'm sure
you prefer me to say they watch the
program and are blessed by the
information. Mhm.
So, [clears throat] God continue to
bless you, my good doctor. God continue
to bless you. And thanks for allowing me
to uh hold onto your coattails by
inviting me to speak. I appreciate it.
Uh Elder Skeet, uh the privilege is ours
to have you share the word of the Lord.
We bless God for your ministry and your
entire family, your wife and loved ones.
We thank God for your labor of love in
his vineyard. We pray that God restores
your strength and that you're able to
get some wonderful rest. Yes, I will.
And have your strength. Okay.
Thank you. Thank you, Elder Skeet. God
bless you. God bless.
All right, everyone. Thank you so much
for joining our Q&A session with Elder
Randy Skeet. And I pray on law and
grace. And I pray that we now have a
better understanding of God's
requirements for our lives and the fact
that he gives us grace to grow in
Christ, to be drawn closer to him.
So, now
Pastor Dixon or Jonathan Dixon and his
wife Courtney Dixon will share a special
music recording, rather,
uh Draw Me Nearer. Draw Me Nearer. We
pray you're blessed.
I am [singing] thine,
O Lord. I have heard
thy voice and it [singing] told thy love
to [music] me.
But I long [singing]
to rise in the arms of [singing]
faith and be closer
drawn [singing] to
thee.
Draw me [singing] nearer,
nearer, blessed Lord, to the cross where
thou
[singing]
hast died.
[music]
Draw me nearer, [singing]
nearer, blessed Lord,
to thy precious
bleeding
side. [singing]
Consecrate
me now to thy [singing] service,
Lord, by the power
of grace divine. [singing]
May my soul look up with a [singing]
steadfast
hope and my will be lost in thine.
Draw me nearer,
[singing]
nearer, blessed Lord, to the cross where
thou hast
died. Draw me nearer, [singing]
nearer, blessed [singing]
Lord,
to thy [singing] precious
bleeding
side.
Oh, the pure delight [singing]
of a single
hour that before thy throne [singing] I
spend.
When I kneel in [singing] prayer and
with thee, my God, I commune
[singing]
as friend with friend.
Draw me [singing] nearer,
nearer, blessed Lord, to the cross where
thou
hast died.
Draw me nearer,
nearer, [singing and music] blessed
Lord,
to thy [singing] precious
bleeding
side.
Draw me nearer, [singing]
nearer, blessed Lord, [singing] to the
cross where thou
hast died.
[singing]
Draw me nearer,
nearer, blessed [singing]
Lord,
to thy precious
bleeding
[singing] side.
To thy precious
bleeding
side.
Amen.
Amen. Amen. Thank you, Pastor Dixon and
Sister Courtney for ministering that
song. May we be drawn closer to Jesus
Jesus' precious bleeding side. Thank you
all for joining this Q&A with Elder
Randy Skeete on law and grace. We pray
that you are blessed. We pray that you
are inspired
to be drawn closer to God and to abide
by his holy law and to live and grow in
his grace. I encourage all of you
to like, share, and subscribe if you are
blessed by this message. And please feel
free to join us September 24th at 2:00
p.m. Eastern Standard Time for a Q&A
with Elder Neville, not Elder, but
Brother Neville Peter on music and my
testimony. Music and my testimony with
Brother Neville Peter. Some of you may
be familiar with his music, with his
testimony, and I'm also seeing him on
the Love Me Channel with those scripture
songs that he has been involved with.
So, feel free to save the date,
September 24th at 2:00 p.m. Eastern
Standard Time for a Q&A with Elder with
Brother Neville Peter on music and my
testimony. Thank you all for your
presence and may God bless you richly.
Before we close this session, I will
invite Sister Sherelle Pierre to give us
our closing prayer.
Good afternoon, everyone. Good
afternoon. I mean, what a mighty God we
serve and what a powerful program this
was. Such a blessing. And let us at this
time just come before the throne and
offer a word of prayer.
So, let us bow our heads and
close our eyes. Dear Lord, Father in
heaven, we are thankful that you are a
great God, that you are a God of love
and a God of justice. Lord, we thank you
for your kingdom that is founded on your
law. We thank you that you have given
your son so that none should perish, but
that all would have everlasting life.
And we are grateful for that sacrifice
that you gave your all. Forgive us,
Lord, of our sins where we have fallen
short of your commandments. Father,
cleanse us and create in us clean and
renewed hearts. And we ask God that you
would be with each one of us in the
hearing of this program, Lord, and help
us to secure our seat in heaven and that
our salvation would be secured with you
and that we would once again be able to
partake of the tree of life. We are
thankful for your word that is truth
and pray that your Holy Spirit will be
with the ones that are hearing
that it will convict them to follow your
word to be obedient to your law, to your
10 commandment law, which stands
forever. I pray that you would bless
everyone that
was a part of this program, dear God,
from the presenter, Elder Skeete, to
Sister Denisha and all that are
involved. I pray that you would continue
to bless this ministry and may your word
go through the earth with power and with
might. And we look forward to your
coming. Help us to be ready, dear Lord.
In Jesus' name. Amen.
Amen. Amen. Thank you so much, Sister
Sherelle, for being here and doing that
prayer. I know you're probably still on
the crusade site or ground, but thank
you so much for
joining here. And friends, just to let
you know, when does the crusade end,
Sister Sherelle?
The with a Pastor Glenn O. Samuels.
Yes, so the crusade tonight is his last
night, but the crusade will be going on
until September 3rd. So, until next
Sabbath. So, there is still time. It has
been so powerful here. Even the power
actually went out under the tent, but he
kept on preaching and the Holy Spirit
just moved and many have been baptized.
I'm so we just invite you all to come on
down. It is 426 Empire Boulevard
and Brooklyn Avenue.
Amen. Amen. Thank you so much for
sharing that, Sister Sherelle.
All right, everyone, thank you for
joining. Thank you for your presence.
Feel free to meditate on these
scriptures that we have discussed. And I
pray that God will bless you all
abundantly. And may the Father of lights
overwhelm you with his goodness, his
mercy, his law, and his grace. Thank you
all and may God bless you. Have a
wonderful rest of the Sabbath.